the image Paris wanted to project to a
King on his first state visit
versus reality on the streets debris and
destruction
the aftermath of some of the worst
violence seen for years across France
unrest over pension reform forced the
president to cancel the royal visit amid
condemnation on both sides over
protester attacks and police violence
with similar scenes in Bordeaux
manifestation
the King's first state visit here to
France was to be symbolic honoring
historical ties between the two
countries but macron's decision to push
three plans to raise the retirement age
to 64 without a vote has transformed the
streets of Paris into scenes of chaos a
city known for its elegance and Grandeur
and now look at this charred rubbish
broken glass and damage on the streets
of Paris it jars with the very idea of a
state visit full of Pomp and ceremony
and it would have only reinforced the
image of a leader described as
dangerously out of touch
parisians welcomed the decision to
cancel the royal visit but said the
country's problems remain
yes it was a good idea to postpone the
visit because we shouldn't be showing
these dramatic views of France and in
particular Paris right now
the president as of the matters he needs
to deal with at the moment the king's
visit changes nothing for us this won't
change our situation maybe he thinks
it's respectful or even that it was a
bad idea but actually he's more
concerned about the king's security than
ours but so far no sign the unrest will
stop and nothing meaningful to help
clear up the political mess Left Behind
Adele Robinson Sky News Paris